i believe that there's a pretty good  chance that we will finally see the usbc  ports on the upcoming iphone 14 pro so  let's get right into it we already have  leaks pointing to apple switching to  usbc on the iphone 14 pro and with the  iphone 13 pro you can now record pro res  video which takes up a massive amount of  storage space some very solid leaks and  rumors point to the iphone 14 pro coming  with a brand new 48 megapixel main  camera that can shoot 8k video it'll  literally take over an hour to transfer  only around 6 minutes of 8k prores  footage and transfer speeds with usbc  are much faster than lightning and both  the biden harris administration and the  european union are pushing for usbc  ports on all devices apple could switch  to usb-c while at the same time removing  the cable from the box to help save the  environment and obviously save apple  cash